mesmo tomando toneladas de vitamina C
você pode estar sabotando a sua produção
de colágeno por isso é importante
fornecer ao corpo as ferramentas
necessárias para manter a produção de
colágeno em níveis saudáveis e uma
dessas ferramentas principais é manter
níveis bons de cobre no organismo esse
mineral é o nutriente número um para
impulsionar o colágeno O cobre é um
cofator importante para as enzimas que
catalisam a formação das ligações entre
as moléculas de colágeno o que aumenta a
resistência a estabilidade das fibras
explicando melhor pessoal quando seu
corpo produz colágeno uma das últimas
etapas super importantes do processo é
quando as moléculas de colágeno são
Unidas em fibras extremamente fortes de
tecido conjuntivo e o cobre é o
nutriente que faz essa mágica acontecer